[Music]
joining me this week is an author a
nationally syndicated radio host a
columnist and the creator of Prager
University right here on the YouTube and
a Frager welcome to the Reuben report
Dave great to be with you so somehow
we've only met once although I feel that
were in the same space and that I know
you sort of just threw your public self
but the one time we met we were on Larry
King's show on my old home Laura yeah
and you know they bring you on as a
conservative and they brought me on as
the liberal and I think it was a little
bit around my kind of waking up to what
was happening with the left and we kind
of agreed on a lot not on everything but
we agreed on a lot do you find that odd
that sometimes you can agree with a
liberal because you are a conservative I
can agree with a liberal I can't agree
with a leftist I make the distinction
between liberal or left constantly
because it needs to be made the left is
an enemy of liberalism and I love
liberalism uncalled a conservative but
the irony is I don't know pretty much of
any value that I changed since I was a
liberal remember I was born in New York
but eh yeah be a Jew yeah see Columbia
so that's a lot of losers right exactly
that's a lot of Democratic stuff that's
Riley yes exactly so that was a given to
me you were all those three things it's
like I wish on my birth certificate it
had you know on the days when you still
had gender yeah and you're male you know
political affiliation liberal yeah or or
Democrat right so it was just a given
but I haven't changed my values the the
left has taken over the word liberal and
so therefore I consider those values
inimical to everything liberalism stood
for so one of the things that I've been
saying is that lately defending my
liberal values is becoming a
conservative position now I suspect
that's why that's what I'm waiting what
you felt when when does that change for
you so with their age for me
uh there were two seminal issues yeah
what I knew I was not on the left when
during the Vietnam War which I was in
college and I knew communism was evil
and my life is devoted to fighting evil
that's what I care about more than
anything I hate people who hurt people
deliberately I hate them
I want them destroyed I want evil
destroyed I have a I have not wavered in
that passion since high school that's
all I really I mean I care about a
million things but that's my greatest
care I want to destroy evil Nazism
communism Islamism you name it and the
left didn't the left hated Nazis but
they didn't hate communists so it meant
they didn't hate evil and that's my
first realization that I wasn't on the
left so but I still thought I was a
liberal but not on the left and then
Ronald Reagan came and in one sentence
it all turned for me and then I became a
Republican and that was a government is
not the solution it's the problem and
and that was an epiphany mm-hmm and I
thought that's right there were truths
that are so real that if you have an
open mind it doesn't take more than five
seconds to realize it does that
necessarily make you a Republican or
does that really just make you a
classical liberal and I know I always
say on this show I have to use a lot of
these terms that I think are starting to
lose meaning but we need them just to
throw no I'm going to say a vote of
labels go fine but so what made you then
say okay well now in the Republican
because that you could use that Reagan
quotes a bomb a classical liberal its
liberal individually all right limited
government s but the home for classical
liberalism is the Republican party to
the extent that they're not big
government people which george w bush
was for example but the only home
between democrats and republicans
for limited government people is the
republican party yeah
do you sense that changing now we
obviously we're gonna have to talk a
little bit about trump here i think at
first maybe you you weren't supporting
him and then you kind for grudgingly
were and then i think basically you
supported him as a bee
iiiiii actually I'm proud to say all the
time will tell whether I will be proud
to say yeah but I was thoroughly
consistent I was opposed to him the most
among all the Republicans and I wrote
piece after piece a National Review Town
Hall in other places where my column
appears I what I I was as anti-trump as
anyone but I wrote from my first column
if he wins the nomination I will vote
for him and my my thinking was clear in
retrospect was clear I gay I kept giving
this analogy if you have two doors over
one door it says man-eating lion and
over the other it says maybe a man I
will open them maybe a man-eating lion
door right I don't see it is a big
dilemma so this really was more of a
reflection of your feelings on Hillary
than anything else no no no it's smart
but whether that feelings on the Left
defeating the left is as great a moral
urgency as defeating Islamism those are
the two enemies of Western civilization
as we know it and I say that I would
sadness there are a lot of nice people
on the left but probably not that many
nice Islamists ala Greg back yeah but
this would be too thrilled about this
they would not go to brooklyn-born Jews
yes kind of well the left wouldn't be
too thrilled with this to see right
we're going to get into a little bit of
that yeah well I like that but I mean it
sincerely look look at what they're
doing to the university the university
is now becoming a fistic place literally
with the old semi quasi violent
suppression of dissenting voices and the
reason it is the only place the left
runs without opposition so when the left
is free to do what it wants just look at
you yolk local university and you see
what's happening okay so then what's
happening there what do you think is go
in the mind and I was around these
people a lot for a long time and I don't
know that I have the right answer
what is happening where they have
created this system of what now I'm
calling the oppression Olympics where
you know your victimhood is the highest
virtue that you can write have and we
have to place everybody's victimhood
below yours because that means you're
better than and all that stuff
what happened there what where did this
come from well for what there are many
many ads very hard analyzing the left
has been as complex to me as you know
the search for string theory is among
physicists because it's so emotional
that there isn't a logical consistency
one answer to your question is the the
left does not divide the world between
good and bad I do but the left doesn't
the left divided between rich and poor
and strong and weak so or victim and
victimizer so you get you don't get your
strength from being right you get your
strength from being a victim from being
the underdog that's the reason the left
is pro-palestinian
anyone with a moral compass that works
some of the time knows that there is no
comparison between Israel and the
Palestinians morally speaking but the
Left roots for the Palestinians because
not because because they don't measure
by good and bad they measure by weak and
strong black and white West and non West
first world and third world but not good
and evil so that's a big factor that's
taking place on the campus how do you
define good Nebo before you go at the
same way the same way you do I mean it's
not a trick issue a good is treating
people decently is having openness to
opposing views without suppressing them
is not building concentration camps I
mean it this is not this is not if not
outright sides exactly yeah so last time
I saw you was at your Prager University
event and you gave the the keynote
speech with rocky no jr. and I it was
right before the election and I sensed
that you actually do want to build some
bridges with these people which is
probably partially why were sitting down
that you weren't I didn't think you were
really dear to clear you don't like
what's happening with the modern left
but I do sense that you're trying to
figure out a way to reach out to some of
these people which is what you're doing
with Prager you are you seeing any real
attraction in waking some of these
people out the although I know we're
waking some people up because there is
no not one of the hundred fifty
pre-university videos they're all to
roll 5 ministers and some really fine
thinkers give them not one of them yells
at you it's heat here is our position
here is the reason and here are the
facts behind it and have a wonderful day
so it funny that that became not the
norm I mean people say to me all the
time I love your show because you ought
to people that's right well I get that
do you know I get that's funny you
should say that I've been broadcasting
33 years and the most common among the
most common maybe it is the most or it's
among the most common reactions I get
god you know what I really love about
your show is you're calm you know you
never yell in fact I do yell about four
times a year where something will get me
so angry maybe six times a year and I
always apologize because and read and
readers listeners tell me we love it
when you yell because it's so rare yeah
and they realize you know you can really
you can prick me and I'll bleed but uh
it's I just can't stand yelling yeah
well it to be it's sort of like a
well-placed [ __ ] I don't say it that
often even just saying it now I probably
haven't said it on air in quite some
time but that I brought it out you see
you the way you've been raised me here
that you so you feel like you have made
some traction because you're hearing
from people that are saying wow there's
some really the problem is and it is a
problem the the what is the word oh oh
when when you're not taught you are
indoctrinated yeah the indoctrinate
of American kids begins so early you're
taught now in third grade you are taught
in many of the states about carbon
emissions they don't show them a Bjorn
Lomborg video saying that we're wasting
trillions of dollars to lower the
temperature by a fraction of a degree
they don't show them because they don't
believe there are other sides there are
truth tellers and deniers
there were truth tellers and anti
science by the way one of the things as
I studied leftism that was my I studied
communist Affairs marks left ISM and one
of the things that they have always
excelled at is one word dismissals of
their ideological enemies so Stalin
called Trotsky Trotsky the father of
Bolshevism he called him a fascist
so Trotsky was a fascist there was no
need to to debate Trotsky you call him a
fascist and then have him killed with an
icepick that and that's that's in a
nutshell what the left of six herb
sexist intolerant xenophobic homophobic
Islamophobic racist bigoted there is no
need to think on the left because you
have a one word dismissal of your
opponents yeah so so far I know that 90%
of my audience listening to this is
going to go all right this Prager guy
for conservative this makes sense I mean
you're you're hitting the keys that that
I get here all the time so what about on
something like science because you just
mentioned tied this seems to me where
the Republicans and the right it just
doesn't add up we're still debating
evolution we're debating climate science
I'm not a scientist I've brought climate
scientists in here who have said in
unison basically they agree by the way
I've had now except not as looks right
their moral case for fossil fuel and I
was happy to talk to him as well and he
takes it from a different angle and I'm
happy to have those conversations and I
don't pretend to know everything so so
there you go but science to me is one of
the things where the right has just know
gone by edges are one of those things
where the left has effectively demonized
the right our pin the position I've
never met somebody on the right who
said the science is wrong it's not
solution for them okay well alright so
if you want evolution fun several issues
very complex issue believe it or not by
the way I don't have a particular axe to
grind I happen to believe in God and my
position for most of my life was okay
God created evolution I have no issue so
things can concurrently I'll even what I
think on my position any longer because
I simply no more science and that the
science on evolution is not nearly as
established as people think it is
because the the paleontologists
themselves are not so certain that it
occurred in anywhere near the way they
believe it did to two quick things on
that one is of course I just it just
needs to be stated that evolution has
zero explanation I mean zero none for
the creation of life there is no there
is no evolutionary jump between
inorganic and organic and and they
acknowledge that they just say one day
they'll find one but there isn't one
so the evolutionist has nothing to say
about the origin of life they have
something to say about the origin of
species once life begins but that's a
big difference the second part is they
don't have a lot to say even on the
Origin of Species when when you look at
it was this thing called the Cambrian
was it the Cambrian my wife knows she's
going crazy because she's in the other
she's visiting the real Navin on this
but the K I'll do and I have any Hadrian
a explosion that's it the option yeah
this was when vast numbers of species
arose but much too quickly for evolution
to have accounted for them and there
were so many qualified scientists who
have taken this on even even the famous
Harvard paleontologist has passed away
whose name he eludes me for the moment
but he he wrote about this he was in it
was an atheist or agnostic you know but
he said he had punctuated evolution
where it which is almost an oxymoron
because
it you know we're just things a portal
isn't a lot area anyway my only point is
that it's not as clear as they make now
if somebody says to you I don't believe
that the world was created in billions
of years that they're you know the world
it was created in six 24-hour periods
called days that is a rejection of the
science all right matter that's right
okay so I'm glad you're making that
young-shin because we can neither one of
us our evolutionary biology so yes we
can say as much as we know and that by
the way just for the record just today I
had a interview with Jerry Coyne who's a
world-renowned evolutionary biologist
right would I'm sure take issue with
some of the things you're saying here
right but we don't have to bicker over
those little things but usually when
someone look at the literal six-day
thing and write all that your but here I
just want to say yeah give me I really
yeah no I do like yeah let's get it I
don't give a hoot if somebody believes
God created the world of 60 24-hour
period I care if they if they reject
vaccines if they don't give blood
transfusions in other words I don't care
what people believe yeah I care how
people behave there's a very important
principle in my life so if you happen to
believe that God created the world which
I don't because the science negated yeah
but if you believe and I believe that
the Bible is divine and all that good
stuff but but nevertheless if you do
believe that here it is possible to be a
professor of medicine and believe God
created the world in six days I know
that sounds oxymoronic but it isn't
religious belief is religious belief and
scientific belief decided to believe for
many people I like to reconcile them but
some just say I'm not reconciling them
this is what it says I take it and now I
would like to go back to my medical lab
please to do research on cancer right so
in some way though is that
reconciliation sort of living the
difference
what you truly believe me Dennis yeah no
immaterial well I believe in science and
religion I think that there's a conflict
at all truth is truth
yeah God there's a Hebrew saying the
signature of God is truth if something
is true I must believe it because it's
true
I am religiously obligated to believe it
if it's true right so if a doctor free
let's say you had to have heart surgery
or something and you had two doctors to
choose from and what and they had the
same exact set you know medical
background right one of them said I
believe in evolution and science and all
that tell me like I said well you know
the earth was created in six days and
guys right I wouldn't look the coin so
that would have had no meaning usually
really environmental eyes absolutely no
no because they can take them right not
because I can right I know you're not
been prioritizing they can all right
because I know you see here's the
interesting thing there are a lot of
Orthodox Jews I'm a religious Jew but
not Orthodox yeah but there are a lot of
so I have this not no ax to grind there
are a lot of Orthodox Jews who are
doctors who are physicists who are
chemists biologists how is that possible
they believe the Torah is from God and
they then go to the lab and do wonderful
scientific work so obviously they've
lived they live with both yeah so what
does that say about humans in general
that we're just able to live with well
alright I have an interesting theory on
that ah this is why the left scares me
more than you know the left is scared by
religious Christians for example I'm not
scared by religious Christians at all
and again I emphasize on I got your
Prager you card I mean it said Merry
Christmas I freaked out and I you know I
sent the letter to the FBI but I don't
know I know that number we were we were
interviewed yeah I told us you sent them
ah the the fear that they have is not is
not comparable and here is a theory so
here's my theory
I the human being clearly needs to
believe some non rational things I
believe that that is
part of what the human mind must have so
the religious person the healthy and I'm
talking our healthy religious and
healthy non-religious apples and apples
the healthy religious person can find
his non rational thought to religiosity
the secular person when they have the
non rational they're much scarier
because that is not about splitting of
seeds or Jesus walking on water it's
about real life the amount of the
non-rational that is believed on the
left that is scary so totally a non
rational in the religious realm is not
necessarily scary it could be you
believe you murder people you get 72
virgins that's scary
yeah but there's a lot of people that
believe you're right that's why I use
Christians yeah America was founded by
fundamentalist Christians who produced
incredibly rational society and the the
competitive marketplace the free-market
Liberty these were very rational ideas
they were very religious men not all but
many of them were so uh you know III and
III welcome secularism in Iran and I
fear secularism in America right that's
what I mean there's something really
there between those two things we
probably have the right society as yeah
yeah so it's interesting because I see
this constant I'm sure you see it to
this constant attacking of straight
white men of Christians all these things
and what you're saying basically is we
were born out of Christianity America
and we become absurdly tolerant and yet
everyone out absurdly Conor I think it's
wonderfully generous yes unique uniquely
right
and yet we have there's just this idea
out there that we are the most
intolerant place how do you how do you
fight those ideas back how you fight if
the irrational is very hard it's very
hard because you can give evidence
I give evidence for America being the
least racist society that has
multi-racial elements in it in history
and it doesn't doesn't convince people
who ever if people have a vested
interest in believing something you
can't talk them out of it and this is
why I fear the left they have their the
world would collapse it is like the the
famous book written when Stalin made his
pact with Hitler all these communists in
the left who had followed who had
followed Stalin not all many of them
thought oh my god I've been believing in
nonsense my whole life the God that
failed it's a very famous book from I
think the 50s or maybe the 40s and and
it was about that the the the left why
do people believe in communism I mean it
is it is drivel
the thing is drivel but when people drop
judeo-christian religions catholicism
protestantism evangelicalism Mormonism
judaism when people drop those they
don't stop yearning for religious
certitude so what they end up with is
secular religious certitudes and they
are at least as scary so i don't think
you would quite word it this way but I
guess I would worry as they get there
letting go of the sort of easier answers
that religion might provide and then
it's a little easier to sway them in the
secular arena would you say that yes
every day although I don't guess you
would word it quite that I don't know
that's one that's fine and it's also
easier for another reason
secularism makes no moral demands on you
tells you there is no God who judges you
so it's awesome you feel great about
yourself by taking the right position on
any left-wing issue I love I love blacks
I love gays I love Muslims I love
whatever the victim of the month is and
I'm a wonderful human being my daughter
is a great girl really does she cheat on
tests I don't know but she does in fact
she she does 10k run for breast cancer
that doesn't make you a daughter a good
girl that's a very sweet thing that she
does but you weren't you are judged by
your character right and there's no more
character emphasis
[Music]
you